عاد دوني الليلة لإلقاء نظرة على كيف
يمكن للذكاء الاصطناعي تزييف أصواتنا بما في ذلك أصواتنا، مرحبًا أمي، مرحبًا،
أبدو مختلفًا بالنسبة لك، نعم، لقد
قلت ذلك لسينيد للتو وقلت إنني لست بحاجة إلى
بعض الأمريكيين،
هذا ليس أنا في الواقع، هذا صوت
مصنوعة بواسطة الكمبيوتر،
يا إلهي، هل أنت جاد،
نعم أنا آسف، لقد حدث
انفجار في الصوت المزيف والأصوات التي يتم
إنشاؤها من خلال تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي، هذه
نسخة مستنسخة من صوت والتر وايت بالذكاء الاصطناعي،
هذه نسخة مستنسخة من الذكاء الاصطناعي لصوت ليوناردو
دي كابريو  كل ما تحتاجه هو
تسجيل صوت أي شخص لمدة دقيقتين
ويمكنك جعل الأمر يبدو وكأنه
قال أي شيء حتى
أندرسون كوبر، لقد جئنا هنا إلى جامعة كاليفورنيا في
بيركلي اليوم للتحدث مع هاني فريد،
خبير الطب الشرعي الرقمي حول مدى
سهولة ذلك  إنه وضع الكلمات في
أفواه الآخرين، إنه أمر ممتع للغاية
بالتأكيد ولكنه أيضًا مخيف حقًا، أعتقد أنه
بمجرد وضع عامل الأزيز هذا جانبًا،
لا أعتقد أن الأمر يستغرق وقتًا طويلاً للنظر
في المخاطر، هذا هو وولف بليتزر آني
فريد، أنت في غرفة الموقف التي
تقول هذا جيد، نعم من خلال تحميل
بضع دقائق فقط من أصواتي وبعض
أصوات زملائي إلى خدمة صوتية تعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي، وقد
تمكنت من إنشاء بعض
المقاطع المزيفة المقنعة بما في ذلك صوت أندرسون
كوبر ودوني أوسوليفان.  قطعة حقيقية
من الهراء،
الذكاء الاصطناعي يفعل ذلك حقًا، هذا كل
شيء، نعم، أندرسون رجل جيد حقًا
لأن أندرسون ليس لديه
لهجة أيرلندية غبية، لقد
عانت التكنولوجيا مع لهجتي الأيرلندية ولكننا
قررنا أن نضع الأمر على المحك النهائي
مع بلدي  والدي أنا على وشك محاولة
الاتصال بأمي في أيرلندا
ومعرفة ما إذا كان بإمكاني خداعها بهذا
الصوت، نعم أعتقد أنني
سأنجح، أنا متوتر، أشعر أن يدي
بخير،
مرحبًا
أمي مرحبًا  دوروثي، كيف
انتهيت للتو من تصوير قصتنا هنا،
سأذهب إلى المطار بعد فترة،
ويبدو أن هناك تأخيرًا في الهاتف، توني، هل
يمكنني إلقاء التحية السريعة على أبي،
نعم
كيف حالك هنا، مرحبًا أبي،
كيف
حالك فقط  انتهيت من تصوير قصتنا
هنا،
سأذهب إلى المطار بعد فترة
وسيعود إذا كانت
كاري تلعب في نهاية هذا الأسبوع،
ذهب والدي لإجراء محادثة
مع AI dhoni حول كيف
لعب فريق كيري لكرة القدم في موطننا مباراة في نهاية هذا
الأسبوع في نهاية المطاف  كان علي أن أوضح الأمر يا
أبي، سأتصل بك بشكل أفضل لاحقًا،
هل يمكنك إعادتي إلى أمي
للحظة، كان والداي يعلمان أن شيئًا ما كان
خاطئًا ولكن في النهاية ما زالا يقعان في غرامه،
أعني بعض
نعم
لأنني ذهبت أوه و  يا صديقي كان قلبي
نصف في البداية أوه أنا آسف، الجهاز
مضحك للغاية
سأتصل بك لاحقًا يا أبي،
وداعًا، هذا ليس كلاسيكيًا، الأم تبدو
وكأن هناك شيئًا خاطئًا مع ابني،
الأب مثل كل شيء على ما يرام،
أود أن أغلق  أخرج حفل اليوم
بسؤال، إذا تم إعطاؤك
خيارًا، فهل ستختار الحصول على عدد
غير محدود من لحم الخنزير المقدد، لكن لن تكون هناك المزيد من ألعاب الفيديو التي
ستزيف تسجيلات بايدن وترامب التي
تنتشر على الإنترنت، ويقول فريد إن هذا
قد يكون شيئًا يجب الحذر منه قبل
خوض انتخابات 2024 عندما نكون  أدخل
هذا العالم حيث يمكن لأي شيء أن يكون مزيفًا
أي صورة أي صوت أي مقطع فيديو أي جزء
من النص لا شيء يجب أن يكون حقيقيًا لدينا
ما يسمى أرباح الكذاب وهو
أنه يمكن لأي شخص أن ينكر الواقع من شأنه أن يؤدي إلى
طوفان من أدوات الذكاء الاصطناعي الجديدة التي يتم إطلاقها عبر الإنترنت،
كما يقول الشركات التي تطور هذا
تحتاج التكنولوجيا القوية إلى التفكير في
آثارها السلبية المحتملة، لا يوجد
عالم متصل بالإنترنت أو غير متصل بالإنترنت، هناك
عالم واحد متكامل تمامًا عندما
تحدث الأشياء على الإنترنت، تكون لها
آثار حقيقية على الأفراد
والمجتمعات والمجتمعات من أجل
الديمقراطيات، ولا أعتقد أننا كذلك  لقد
تمكن أحد المجالات من التعامل بشكل كامل مع
مسؤوليتنا هنا في هذه الأثناء، سأستمر في
إزعاج زملائي هنا،
هذا الشيء الذي قاله أندرسون إنني أفعل
هذا منذ وقت طويل، ويجب أن أقول إن توني
أوسوليفان ربما يكون الأفضل في هذا
المجال  لا يصدق جيد جدًا، إنه
لطف منه أن يقول حسنًا، أنت تعلم أنه
يجب تكريمك حقًا،
لن أقول أبدًا ذلك
أم لا، أنت كذلك، لذلك هذا رائع
بالنسبة لي، إنه لأمر مدهش، إنه مضحك،
إنه مخيف أيضًا أعني كما أشرت  في
هذه القطعة،
يمكنك الاستماع إلى صوت شخص ما وهو الاتصال
بأمك وأنت تعلم أن لديك عملية
احتيال ضدها قائلة إنك في
مشكلة ويجب عليك القيام بذلك لتحويل الأموال
على الفور، نعم أعني أن والدي
لن يصدقوا أبدًا أننا لطيفون جدًا
اتصل بهم مرة أخرى قائلين: هل
هذا دوني أم حقًا
ولكن انظر، لقد استمتعنا
به قليلًا ولكن هذه التكنولوجيا
قوية جدًا لإنشاء صورة مزيفة عميقة
لك، فنحن نحتاج فقط إلى دقيقة أو دقيقتين من
الصوت.  لا يصدق ويمكنك
البدء فورًا في الكتابة ووضع الكلمات
في فمك، نعم،
يبدو الأمر واضحًا ونحن نتجه نحو
انتخابات 2024، فكر في الدور الذي
لعبه الصوت في الحملات السابقة،
شريط Access Hollywood أه شريط رومني
أه النسبة المئوية وحتى نوع  تقوم
ووترغيت بتسجيل كل هذا النوع من
الأشياء، وكذلك كما ذكرت
نوع عمليات الاحتيال التي تخدع الناس، وقد
قام موقع Vice بعمل تقرير حيث
تمكنوا من اقتحام حساب مصرفي
له صوت، أفكر في الأمر من
منظور شخص ما  لقد مات
وشخص عزيز عليه يريد أن
يسمع صوت أحبائه،
وحتى أنك تعرف التواصل معهم،
فهذا هو الإمكانية التي
يمكن القيام بها في المستقبل والتي سيكون من السهل القيام بها الآن وكذلك
باستخدام شيء مثل الدردشة gbt حيث يمكنك
يمكنني تقليد ما سيقولونه بشكل صحيح،
نعم كلاهما معًا، إنه أمر لا
يصدق، لم أسمع سوليفان شكرًا
جزيلاً